as we all focus on physical and mental
wellness let's not forget financial
wellness clark county credit union is
here to help
shannon welcome back
thank you thanks for having me so let's
talk about the clark county credit
union's services that they provide of
the community when it comes to healthy
finances and teaching your family
right so we know it's it's on the
parents you want to give them resources
we have free resources on our website
and the partner we have is bonsai and so
we have calculators articles tons of
different ways that people can learn
um about healthy finances but one of my
favorites is a personal wellness
assessment
uh we won't call it a quiz but it is an
assessment oh gosh the kids will say no
yeah so you can go online it's free um
you don't have to be a member of clark
county credit union but you can go
online and just answer a few questions
it takes about five minutes and you'll
get an assessment of where you are on
your financial journey with tips for
what you should focus on what you should
improve on and kind of what's next for
you
wow that's great so what kind of
questions what kind of questions should
we be prepared to answer here
give me a study guide yeah so i mean
kind of like when you go to the doctor
if you don't tell them all about your
symptoms you're not really going to get
an accurate diagnosis so i will
encourage you to be honest with your
responses but you'll just go through and
think say things like you know can i pay
all of my bills do i have money left
over for saving what
rate do i have on maybe a mortgage or an
auto loan and then when you fill those
all out it's going to give you a score
out of 100 and it'll let you know where
you are and what you need to work on and
we all have blind spots we all have
things we need to work on so it'll tell
you here's some resources for the next
step
okay so for example when i'm done with
the assessment at the end of it it'll
tell me you need to save more or you
need to you know work on that debt how
does how does that work what do they
tell you right so after you take the
test you'll be kind of grouped into four
categories it's like are you a thinker a
planner
a builder or an inventor and those are
just where you are with your finances
and it'll say hey you're in that like
building stage maybe you need to start
looking at more 401k investments or
maybe you're still like in that thinking
stage and here's some education for you
to really start making a budget or
something basic i mean one of the
questions that they ask you is um could
you cover an unexpected 1 000 expense
and then how do you feel about that what
are the emotions behind that like for
some people that's
really going to cause anxiety and be
scary whereas some are like i'm good i
feel solid about that and so the
emotions behind money that's huge right
like how do i feel and so there's even
tools for helping you manage that
anxiety manage those emotions as well so
how can people get more information or
contact you guys if they have questions
so first of all go to our website
ccculb.org and you'll find bonsai which
is our financial tool
or we have six branches around the
valley you can always visit them or call
us at
two eight 702-222-8228 we can help you
out
thank you to clark county credit union
for sponsoring this segment again call
them at
702-228-2228 or visit
ccculv.org for their free or their
special offer a free financial wellness
assessment